is clearly best girl and top waifu in
Demon Slayer but did you know that she
also has a tragic past and that she has
some of the coolest and most unique
powers out of any hashira by the end of
this video you will know everything you
need to know about the waifu hashira
what makes her so unique in terms of her
powers and abilities and why she is one
of the most heroic and important
characters in the story there is so much
Essential Demon's air info in this video
so be sure to watch until the very end
you won't regret it mitsuri kanoji is
the love hashira and she uses her own
unique breathing style Called Love
breathing love breathing is a derivative
of flame breathing and when she first
joined the demon sire Corps mitsuri was
actually trained by the flame hashira
kyojiro rengoku he is the one who taught
her how to use breathing Styles and I'll
talk more about that later but first
let's talk about how and why mitsuri
became a Demon Slayer in the first place
mitsuri was born to to a family of five
children and her family was close and
they got along well when tanjiro asks
her why she became a hashira she tells
him that she did it so that she could
find a man to marry you might have been
confused by this statement when you
first heard it but once we consider
mitsuri's backstory it all starts to
make sense ever since she was a child
mitsuri was different from other people
she has naturally pink hair which is
apparently the result of her eating too
much Sakura Mochi but even though you
might assume that that's just a gag that
the author inserted into the story as
lighthearted comedic relief mitsuri's
hair color actually plays an important
role in her backstory her hair color is
so different from the norm that she
stood out from everyone else and because
taisho era Japan was a highly
traditionalist Society where standing
out was not a good thing mitsuri had a
really tough time fitting in on top of
that from a very young age she ate a lot
more than the average person and she
also became a lot stronger than the
average person in fact her body itself
is unique it is much more flexible than
a normal human body and she has eight
times more muscle density than the
average human because of this mitsuri
has always been freakishly strong and
because she is a woman her strength made
her an outcast in the traditionalist
society that she grew up in it got so
bad that her engagement was actually
called off because she was considered to
be too weird to marry I am not kidding
at age 17 mitsuri was engaged to be
married but the arrangement was called
off when her husband-to-be decided that
her hair color and strange physique were
repulsive to him and he didn't want her
to pass those genes onto his future
children let's just pause for a second
to appreciate what her fiance did here
he rejected best girl mitsuri because
she was too strong and too flexible and
because she had cute pink hair this dude
is an absolute brozo and this is easily
one of the top 5 biggest L's in the
history of anime if you agree with that
statement drop a quick like right now
for that YouTube algorithm and don't
forget to subscribe to the channel so
you can be notified next time we publish
a Demon Slayer video and trust me it's
gonna be soon now we can joke about
mitsuri's fiance being a massive Bozo
and that is definitely what he is but
this rejection from her husband to be
absolutely devastated mitsuri I mean no
one likes rejection especially not when
that rejection happened because of
something you've been insecure about
your entire life but we have to remember
that there's also a social aspect to
this being rejected by her husband to be
in such a traditionalist society would
put mitsuri and her family in a very
difficult situation people love to
gossip and if word gets around that
mitsuri was rejected by her fiance then
other potential suitors will lose
interest if someone else rejected her
there must be something wrong with her
right it's a stupid way of thinking but
that's just the way it was so after her
engagement was broken off mitsuri
decided to make some serious changes she
started to change herself in order to
fit in with the rest of society and this
includes both physical and personality
changes she dyed her pink hair black she
pretended to be weak and fragile and she
ate much less than she needed to so that
people wouldn't be intimidated by her
massive appetite because of this she was
often so malnourished that she would
faint and she was actively hurting her
own health just to fit into that
society's definition of what a proper
woman and wife should be and the changes
worked mitsuri started to actually fit
in with the rest of society and
potential suitors became interested in
her again but even though this is what
mitsuri thought she wanted she just
didn't feel like herself anymore she
felt like she wasn't being her true self
and that she was just living a lie in
order to please other people luckily
mitsuri eventually met kagaya ubiashiki
the leader of the Demon Slayer core and
this encounter finally changed her life
for the better instead of being freaked
out by her unusual strength ubiashiki
believed that mitsuri's strength was a
gift from God anyone who speaks ill of
her incredible natural talents is just
jealous and there is nothing wrong with
a girl who is strong mitsuri finally
found the true acceptance with uyashki
and the demon Slayers and she was
finally able to be herself inside the
Demon Slayer core her strength wasn't
something that was weird and looked down
upon it was actually a huge Advantage a
blessing from God and it allowed mitsuri
to become an excellent Demon Slayer on
top of that mitsuri's unique physical
talents allowed her to fight demons and
save the lives of innocent people which
is something that she never would have
been able to do as effectively if her
physique was normal and average her
greatest insecurity suddenly became her
biggest Advantage something that she
didn't have to be ashamed of but could
actually be proud of with all that said
mitsuri's comment that she became a
demon sir in order to find a husband was
isn't just a me mitsuri really does want
to find a husband and she wants to find
one who will not be intimidated by her
strength so she thought that becoming a
Demon Slayer would allow her to meet
many strong men and hopefully she could
one day marry one of them however things
didn't go exactly as planned because
mitsuri was much stronger than the vast
majority of demon Slayers and she
quickly Advanced to the rank of hashira
as I mentioned earlier mitsuri was
trained by kyojiro rengoku she initially
learned his flame breathing style of
swordsmanship but she later modified it
into her own custom style known as love
breathing love breathing is unique
because it takes full advantage of
mitsuri's special physique including her
superhuman flexibility and muscle
density there are extra chapters in The
Demon Sarah manga called the rengoku
Gaiden chapters and although these are
separate from the main story they are
still considered canon in the rengoku
guide in it we get a glimpse of rengoku
training mitsuri and we even see the
moment and mitsuri gets her first
official Demon Slayer uniform believe it
or not her uniform is a normal
regulation Demon Slayer uniform at least
for women after rengoku expresses his
desire to become the next flame hashira
ubiashiki gives him the opportunity to
prove himself by defeating lower moon to
Jairo who has been threatening the
capital city of Tokyo rengoku takes
mitsuri on this Mission with him and
this is the first big mission that they
go on together the battle against lower
Moon 2 turns out to be an extremely
valuable learning experience for mitsuri
and she really learns a lot from rengoku
and not only in terms of his fighting
style she also learns a lot about his
character and the van Goku inspires her
to keep going and to keep doing her best
as a Demon Slayer in many ways rengoku
was also an outcast just like mitsuri he
too has extremely unusual hair his
clothes are unconventional for the time
period he carries a sword everywhere he
goes even though that was not socially
appropriate during the the taisho period
and so on because their mission takes
them to Tokyo which is full of people
rengoku gets multiple comments about
being strange and weird and scary but he
just brushes them off in stride and
continues to smile and do his job this
inspires mitsuri to follow in rengoku's
footsteps it is during the fight against
lower Moon 2 Hyrule that mitsuri begins
to develop her own unique breathing
style love breathing which was as I said
greatly inspired by rengoku's Flame
breathing ultimately loremoon 2 haido is
destroyed by the burning determination
of rengoku and as a result kyojiro
replaces his father shinjuro as the
flame hashira at the same time mitsuri
realizes that with kyojuro and the other
demon Slayers she has finally found a
place where she can be herself and where
people accept her and appreciate her for
who she really is this allows her to tap
into her full potential and rise to the
rank of hashira now let's talk about all
the incredible powers and abilities that
mitsuri possesses many of which are
completely unique to her and unmatched
by anyone else in the series as I
alluded to earlier she was born with a
unique physique including muscles that
are eight times denser than the muscles
of a regular human this gives her
superhuman physical strength and
endurance and allows her to deliver
incredibly powerful attacks while also
making her able to absorb a lot more
damage than the average person mitsuri
is also unbelievably flexible and she
incorporates this flexibility into her
fighting style her combat technique uses
challenging acrobatic Maneuvers that
most of her opponents simply aren't
expecting and the unique design of her
special nitrogen blade Makes Her Moves
even more unconventional and
unpredictable mitsuri's Katana features
a custom design that is completely
different from the swords used by other
demon Slayers her sword blade is very
long thin and flexible and it functions
more like a sharp whip than a sword its
design and construction was so complex
that it had to be done by the chief of
the swordsmith village personally and
any other person who tries to use this
sword would likely injure themselves
horribly but mitsuri's unique body
composition and flexibility allow her to
use the whip like Katana without hurting
herself the unconventional design of her
weapon makes it possible for mitsuri to
perform impressive acrobatic long-range
moves that simply cannot be done with
other swords and wither sword she is
able to achieve speeds that even other
extremely fast hashira like tengenuzui
are simply unable to achieve her
whip-like Neutron blade also allows
mitsuri to bring out the full potential
of Love breathing as I said a few times
love breathing is derived from flame
breathing which is in turn derived from
the original Sun breathing that said
love breathing is unique because it is
based on the emotion of Love rather than
on some sort of natural natural element
or substance and it was developed around
mitsuri's very distinct fighting style
which incorporates her unconventional
whip-like sword and her extraordinary
bodily structure love breathing has five
known forms including first form Shivers
of lost love an attack that involves a
rapid Dash followed by multiple
long-range whip-like slashes second form
love pains which unleashes multiple
whip-like slashes all around the user's
body third form cat love shower which
involves the user leaping into the air
and then releasing a rapid succession of
ranged attacks fifth form swaying love
wild claw which is a backward somersault
through the air that creates a long
string of whipping attacks and sixth
form cat-legged wings of love which
involves the user twirling upside down
and creating Helix shaped slashes that
can deflect enemy attacks there is also
a fourth form but it has not been
revealed so we don't know what it
entails by the way mitsuri is clearly a
cat person since a few of her forms have
cat themed names eventually mitsuri
awakens the Demon Slayer Mark a Demon
Slayer who goes to an extremely tense
and life-threatening situation that sees
their heart rate increase to over 200
beats per minute and their body
temperature go over 39 degrees Celsius
and survives we'll be able to unlock the
Demon Slayer Mark the mark almost always
appears after the user's been in contact
with other demon Slayers who have the
mark Awakening the mark acts as a major
power boost for every Demon Slayer
significantly increasing their strength
speed and endurance but there's a catch
the increased power that comes with the
Demon Slayer Mark comes at the cost of
their lifespan every demon sir who
manifested the mark dies before the age
of 25 although there is one known
exception which was yorichi tsugikuni
yorichi was the strongest Demon Slayer
in history and he was actually born with
his Mark rather than Awakening it later
and he was able to live well into his
80s okay so now that you know mitsuri's
backstory and the full extent of her
power I will give you a spoiler warning
the rest of this video will spoil what
happened in the final arcs of the story
and what role mitsuri plays in those
arcs so if that's something you don't
want spoiled for yourself you can click
off the video right now if you choose to
stay then please proceed with caution
you have been warned along with many of
the other hashira mitsuri plays an
essential role in the final epic battle
against demon daddy moves on after the
infinity Castle is destroyed muzon finds
himself outside in the open he is facing
giyu tanjiro mitsuri and iguro they are
eventually joined by others including
sanami
gomezuko and so on since musan would
survive even if the demon Slayers took
his head the sun is the only true method
of defeating him this means that the
demon Slayers have to hold out until on
and that will not be an easy task at
first muzon seems to be getting even
stronger and faster as the battle
advances and the hashira and other demon
Slayers are finding it impossible to
keep up iguro sees that mitsuri is not
doing well so in an attempt to protect
her he hands her off to the lower ranked
demon Slayers and tells them to take
care of her while he returns to the
battlefield mitsuri cries and says that
she wants to go with him but igoro is
determined to protect her he wishes that
the two of them had met under more
normal circumstances and it's clear that
iguro has strong feelings for mitsuri
however iguro feels that he isn't worthy
of mitsuri because his bloodline is
corrupt and impure his family actually
worshiped a female demon who had the
body of a snake and they had been
feeding their own offspring to this
demon as sacrifices for his entire life
iguro continued to carry the burden of
his family's sins and he had decided
long ago that he wanted to die AI
defeating moves on in order to purify
the filthy blood of his family but if he
were to one day be reborn as a normal
human in a peaceful world without demons
he would finally confess his true
feelings for mitsuri despite being
heavily outnumbered muzan continues to
fight back fiercely but due to the
effects of tamayo's poisons and all of
his many injuries his body is beginning
to break down muzon suffers attack after
attack from tanjiro inosuke and zenitsu
then the injured mitsuri bravely returns
to the battle iguro gets back into the
battle and everyone is fighting
desperately because every second matters
and the Sun is just about to come up as
Dawn finally breaks muzon turns into a
giant baby-like creature in one final
desperate attempt to escape the Sun but
sanami and yomei managed to keep him
from escaping and then as big baby muzon
tries to burrow underground all the
hasida joined together in an app epic
team attack and in the end big baby
moves on is finally destroyed by the
sunlight as muzan perishes iguro is
holding a dying mitsuri in his arms
mitsuri can feel that she is about to
die and igura says that he is dying too
thankfully igro is able to assure
mitsuri that their sacrifice was
worthwhile thanks to their Noble
sacrifices muzon has finally been
defeated the two of them recalled the
first time they met and they reminisce
about all the good times they had
together despite the fact that they were
both considered abnormal by Society they
made each other feel like they were both
normal and there was nothing wrong with
them the two of them made each other
happy and mitsuri asks iguro if they are
reborn as humans again in the next life
could she please be his bride iguro says
yes and he vows that next time around he
will make sure that she is happy and he
will protect her so she doesn't die
young the two of them then pass away
together holding each other in their
arms and as we learn in the final
chapters of the story mitsuri and iguro
are in fact reborn into the modern world
they are now married they have five
children together they own a diner and
they are very happy I know that people
love to meme on Shonen for not having
great female characters but I think that
mitsuri turned out to be an excellent
female character in the end she is both
strong and brave while also being very
feminine she doesn't have to act like a
man in order to project her strength she
also openly talks about wanting a
husband and family while still being a
fierce fighter who risks her life to
help others finally even though she has
many natural gifts and talents for much
of her life those talents were more of a
curse than a gift she had a rough
childhood she dealt with rejection and
insecurity and she struggled to fit in
but in the end she overcame these
challenges with the help of her fellow
demon Slayers she is powerful but she
also had to earn her success so she's
not a Mary Sue like so many of modern
Hollywood's attempts at creating strong
female characters and that is why
mitsuri is such a memorable character
best girl and true waifu material our
boy iguro is a lucky man what do you
guys think of me to this character let
me know down below and if you're looking
for a video to watch next don't ignore
my video on muichiro and his shocking
Family secret Link in the description
and in the pinned comment if you enjoyed
this video and you want to see more
demonstr content here on the channel
leave a quick like right now to let me
know and if you're new to anime outpro
or maybe you watch my videos but you
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a big favor and make this the
video that you subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications